hey guys my name is Jess and on this day
in 1957 the US Army sold the last of its
homing pigeons for more fun facts and
gaming news every single day be sure to
subscribe but for now let's get into it
[Music]
as Bungie gears up for Destiny's final
update age of triumphs it seems as if a
poster and release date for destiny to a
man singh links to pictures of a destiny
to poster have popped up online italian
website ligon at work posted this photo
of a poster that cites the game's
possible release date at September eight
another picture of a different poster
with a slightly different layout was
also posted to imager this time with the
word beta clearly visible Eurogamer and
kotaku have confirmed with sources that
the posters are real recently CEO of
Activision Eric Hirshberg shared some
details on destiny to as part of an
earnings call he said for anyone who
either hasn't yet tried destiny or
hasn't played in a while we think we've
made a sequel that's going to have a lot
for them to love to the cornerstone of
that is a great cinematic story that's
been a real focus with a great cast of
memorable relatable characters coupled
with some very nice ways to make the
game more accessible to a casual player
he also said a big reveal is planned and
that he's going to quote let the game do
most of the talking we'll be bringing
you all the Destiny to info as it
happens but while we wait let me know
what you want from the sequel down in
that combo box good news Xbox fans your
free games with gold for April have been
announced on Xbox one the month kicks
off with rice son of Rome that Crytek
launch title you probably didn't play
then on April 16 riots will be joined by
the walking dead season 2 which isn't a
bad deal at all season 1 was previously
offered to xbox live gold members for
free back in October 2015 if you're
still rocking last generations console
Xbox 360 owners will be able to pick up
Darksiders in the first half of April
and Assassin's Creed Revelations in
second both those games are also
playable on Xbox one through backwards
compatibility before April arrives
though you may want to grab much as
offerings before they disappear they
include layers of fear
a heavy weapon and evolved speaking of
evolved gamers have been grabbing out
the pitchforks for some new DLC pricing
related drama today many Falana cents
left some plates with Ubisoft after
rather bystander double-oh-seven worked
out that to unlock all for honest added
content you'd have to fork out 732
dollars that includes all emotes outfits
and several other minor items game
director demian kian has responded in a
recent Q&A by saying we never had an
intention for you to unlock everything
in the game but us that doesn't really
make any sense let's say in world of
warcraft you would never try to unlock
everything for all the characters same
thing in any mobile we forecasted that
most players will play 1 2 3 characters
and that's what we see today in our game
all of the design is based around that
the cosmetic items for us our endgame
content judging by the reaction from
people in the fauna subreddit fans have
been as we say in Australia less than
stoked with that explanation that is
everything I happy today for more bits
and pieces be sure to stop by gamespot
and come by again for our top five
stories of the whole week